[Music]
[Music]
you sleep before every show I want to
make sense to rest before you go on to
exert all the energy you gonna exert
telling stories well if you could please
sir say your full name to the microphone
my full name is Sadiq Nasir abdullah ali
which you can call me Ali Siddiq
I will call you Ali Siddiq welcome to
the hot breath verse how you doing
brother
I'm doing good man thank you so much for
sitting down with me it's been a
pleasure to watch you work it up town
this weekend absolutely amazing here
just starting off this is an
atlanta-based podcast so kind of like
maybe what's what's your background with
Atlanta Atlanta has a very special place
because this is the first um TV show
that I ever did was here actually
BET's comicview okay center stage Rickey
smiley um what's the host um and that
was the first that was the first thing
the first time that was 1999 Wow yeah I
just got out of prison in 97 so in 99 I
was doing comedy comedy for the first
time and I remember I walked out this is
when before dudes is wearing pants that
came right there I had him first yeah I
had him first you you people go back and
watch it and I had some prada shoes on
and dudes wasn't wearing them in 99 I
know they wasn't so I was flying and I
and I came out and I said you know I'm
pretty much doing this for everybody
who's ever been incarcerated who thought
they could you know will come out and
not do nothing different
that was my first initial statement 1999
bTW and since then I've been doing it
for the same thing for the same reasons
um cuz I'm a cat that you know was
incarcerated and now I'm on Comedy
Central so from convict to Comedy
Central basically and as a convict
that's actually where you started comedy
right yeah I basically started doing
social commentary in prison it wasn't
really stand-up it was like
me saying jovial and funny and
interesting stuff about what were you
saying it you know basically how mostly
everybody starts um but I don't consider
I don't prescribe to that class clown
think ninety-one oh you know what you
claim the clown no not really you know
it was just you know if I say it's
something jovial
or funny if this that's what it was it
wasn't intent it wasn't any antennas I
know you know it's because you're a kid
and you just saying whatever so if you
were nineteen when you yeah I was I got
busted in 1940 I thought turn 19 and you
know I would just say whatever you know
and that was only after Martin went off
because at first I was you know on
clothes cussing I was acting out all of
Martin because they didn't have a TV
because I worked at so then when Martin
went off it kind of forced me into
having support you would just go around
like would people congregate and like
and I'm watching almost like a show
format know it's kind of like
conversation Syd man you say something
funny
mmm-hmm everybody can pretty much hear
you talking cuz you're in a date room
like it's not like it's a lot of privacy
so you happen to say something funny or
you having an argument with somebody you
say something funny then people start
laughing and what you say oh you get up
and you just make a loud statement like
my number one thing I would get up every
morning and say I don't know why y'all
mad cuz ain't nobody going home today
that was dude that was the truth no my
going anywhere so people would be
fighting and doing all that being
uptight cuz they was mad about not going
home mmm-hmm you sign for 30 years you
not going to wear for like 30 years why
you keep looking at the calendar I could
I had a 15-year sentence man I wouldn't
pay attention for drug trafficking right
yeah yeah delivery of a controlled
substance as they say oh man you get 15
years you just doing it you ain't
looking at the days like yogi and your
mind thing okay I'm gonna get out when
I'm 33 what else I got
yeah would you be funny is almost like a
defense mechanism I know
not in laughs I didn't have attack you
or I mean I'm [ __ ] violent man I come
that's the thing about prison and in in
the thing about people being a certain
size I am the exact same [ __ ] sizes
Floyd Mayweather so doesn't matter how
big you are if you run upon for a man
he's gonna beat your ass I'm saying it
in the streets this is what I understood
going into prison
most people have violent crimes with a
committed crime against somebody with
something gun knife
I came up boxing like I'm a good-ass
fighter so I don't give a [ __ ] about you
with your hand with with you how big you
are I ain't cuz in prison I don't have
no [ __ ] weight class ain't no ain't
no one'll a middleweight I'm gonna yo
you say somehow aligning me I'm a bust
show [ __ ] head open and if if he go
past that i'ma try to [ __ ] take your
life because I was like that in the
street so it and I and I and I make it
understand with like like I'm a - OH -
dude I'm talking my prison dudes like yo
man using outer ran through you and I
already know that when people say that
because they looking at me on my small
frame do and I'm like yo I would have
probably killed you cuz I'm the real
just sort of simple fact that you
standing now you didn't trigger
something in my head cuz I'm like yo man
why do people think in their minds that
cuz I've had this question asked me a
lot what would you do it as a defense no
I said what would what would the device
a this is not no [ __ ] Richard Pryor
sketch story ins and Richard Pryor say
he start doing um
stand-up in prison what [ __ ] stretch
of time did Richard Pryor do with what
was that was that documented it I didn't
seen a lot of [ __ ] about Richard Pryor
I've never seen him talk about he was
locked up for what extended of time in
his life
so in the seriousness of it I'd be
telling people you old man I was a lot
of [ __ ] before I was a comic and none of
it had nothing to do with singing loud
and choirs and past now
[ __ ] cookies the kids mmm
using not those type of cookies yeah but
the thing is like out here it's a like
like I try to explain to people it's a
hard transition to be in a society that
doesn't go by rules and like people are
so disrespectful out here in this world
because there's no immediate
consequences see in prison when I was
there
there's immediate consequences if
somebody say something disrespectful to
me
i'ma deal with that that day judge jury
executioner and you don't you you say
something out of line to me and see then
I [ __ ] you up now I'm kind of pigeon
hell because I have children I have
offspring and I want to be there for my
offspring hmm
so if somebody say something out of the
box now I kind of let you ride and it
depends on how severe I take it but with
comedy I take a lot of [ __ ] don't
[ __ ] come in the green room if I
don't ask you to come in the green room
don't take a water don't eat [ __ ] don't
cuz this is not your [ __ ] green room
this is my green room for this weekend
and then next weekend somebody else's
green room and as a comic this is what I
want to say to young comics yo man you
put us in a position sometimes like I
was gonna slap the [ __ ] out this just
white boy in and what's that right
outside Detroit oh the the the the funny
bone Toledo okay I'm went to my hotel
cause it's right across the street I
come in so I know the time in my head
who's all going up so I come back right
on time by the go up and I'm ready now
I call this some guy doing a guest spot
Sacco asked I said on who okay this
guy's fine so I'm asking everybody the
GM said she did okay it soda
DJ decided he want to put up on his
friends mm-hmm but I'm ready to [ __ ]
go up so the guy comes I didn't I didn't
see you so you know X Y and Z's ax so
that mean go up cuz you didn't see me
didn't ask
so here's his friend is sitting there
and I'm and I'm explaining to him hey
man don't ever do that so here I get
this long [ __ ] email and this is why I
like my [ __ ] ass [ __ ] social media
don't [ __ ] email me I was standing
right there when you was talking when I
was talking his [ __ ] friend email me
his long [ __ ] about will use a young
comic before I wasn't a [ __ ] young
disrespectful comic I've never went on
the stage and didn't ask the headliner
could I get a guest spot or get I never
I've never walked in any let me the
rules of comedy for all the [ __ ]
young Communist listen the greenroom is
for the headliner it's not for the
[ __ ] feature it's not for the [ __ ]
host it's for the headliner if I want to
be in that [ __ ] doing cocaine in heroin
and and [ __ ] doing backflips on the
goddamn st. Bernard and I go on stage
that's what the [ __ ] I wanna do that I
wanna do it in private
mm-hmm if I want to sit there with just
sit there naked with my shoes on and
forth until it's time to go on stage
that's actually proper comedy etiquette
because 18 years I've never I performed
with Damon Williams a whole weekend I
never walked in the green room at my
[ __ ] home club mmm Houston improv my
home mm-hmm I never stepped foot in that
green room until he sent his man and his
man said yo Damon say you want I let you
you know sardine i whinny that was
Sunday night I work with him all weekend
I went in Sunday night last show after
the show I win we had a conversation for
the first time
Wow and I'm featuring I never went in
his room in his grandma that's his space
you reference social media you call it
[ __ ] ass social media how do you feel
about these young comedians blowing up
off social media let me just go ahead
and say he's very opinionated about that
and again this is again a moment where
we learn the difference in time okay
what's happening
okay just gonna give him that back cuz
he didn't have that the whole time you
came like gear 12 when your social media
came out Billy Shirelles the aside there
know when I when I when I say [ __ ] at
social media I'm not even speaking about
comedy I'm talking about people who
decide that they gonna write something
on your [ __ ] social media alone [ __ ]
paragraph about how they felt today was
in your face and you could have said
that then you know why you didn't say
that then because I was a knock show
mother [ __ ] head off because you know
what you were saying was [ __ ] stupid
exam so social media is far as comedy
just separate the two social media a lot
of times it's like a text like I could
text you something do you know the tone
of the text do you know the voice of the
text so give you example I'm alright I
took a picture on social media and
people decide they want to say whatever
they want say about social media
somebody gave a reference of what they
felt like something looked like and then
I just simply only saying socially I
said somebody say hey I don't know you
and I don't play like that period then
you decide because you're a good
distance away from me that you will say
something back why I said will do
whatever I want to say and I just said
okay because in my mind I [ __ ] scan
your face and i'ma run into you
eventually one of these days and I'm
going to ask you about that and I'm and
and best belief I am a hundred and sixty
pounds I'm five seven and you can say
whatever you want to say when I'm not
directly in your face
when when I walk up on you I'm a very
formal [ __ ] opponent because in my
mind no regular individual industries
I'm a dude that was in a place that was
filled with the worst people possible
for six years that were stabbed to stab
and kill you any day of the week behind
[ __ ] that you say so it's important to
me what people say to me and what I say
to people because I say something
disrespectful to you then I meet that's
with intent mm-hmm cuz this is coming
from somebody whose mom said if you're
gonna kill someone do it you do it
yourself by yo [ __ ] self your mother
said that to you Widow hen with a
revolver very detailed like yo man you
don't need and everybody know if I get
into you I'm not I don't call no crew I
have one and each crew is like this it's
the same bill it's the same premise when
I was in prison
mmm you in prison you have Lions you
have wolves you have lamb each even if
you are wolf you still have to still be
a lion because you will get separated
from your pack and you still have to be
able to stay on your own but if you just
a wolf and you need your pack then you
can eventually become a lot you can
officially become a lamb hmm
no Lions become lambs you die a lion
so either you don't kill me or I'm going
to kill you there's no other way but am
i intimidated by no means by no means
because you way more formidable
opponents have tried mm-hmm way way more
formidable opponents to try like yo man
you beat them to it it's been a tie
sometimes oh you you kill each other at
the same time yo not we we have done
some very damage they like like I'm
looking at you but I can look at you
straight
but in
i right here I see double every way
besides straight because another lion
damaged me when I was on when I was in
the free society and then I saw that
lion in the enclosed society and then I
damaged him Wow so the damage don't stop
and I damaged him twice cuz I damaged
him in the free society when I shot him
in the stomach in broad daylight because
he did that I was 15 when I saw him
again I was 18 so I held it for three
years then when I saw him in prison I
was 22 so now it's still the same thing
and what he do for you what do you do
dear I got my face was turned
this is dude named Quincy my face was
turned Quincy like six for man he was
probably like a hundred it about two to
something in I was [ __ ] fifteen years
old man I was like five foot maybe a
hundred pounds ten hundred ten and he
knew I was a formal opponent then cuz he
stole me he's doing huge just it just
came home from prison and I had never
been to prison I had never even been a
juvenile Oh until you were 19
yeah it's up you've gotten out of are
you were just you're slick with it yeah
three much as you know mmm veedu but you
know but with comedy man it's a it's a
it's a hard balance because in this
world
I never thought comedy was this [ __ ]
disrespectful
mmm and it's not think it's comedy it's
the people because Billy Billy Billy is
say that we might with my my thing that
he think I don't like young comics I
don't like old disrespectful comics nor
do I like young disrespectful comics and
in comedy it takes a while to understand
how to game even go because you can't I
don't I don't I just don't get how
people think like it's comments out here
social go back to the social media guys
this cash they think that because you
got a million followers up here you are
chick somebody because you got a million
followers that's you actually funny
right did you buy some of your followers
cuz you can do that you know at first I
think you all we got a million file
that's honest but did you purchase some
followers did you boost did you boost
all your [ __ ] this is some [ __ ]
illusion it's an illusion so it's like
seeing a chick on social media and then
you see in real life yeah because she
took a picture at a good angle that
makes her that makes her a real bad
chick so because you edited and did all
this other fancy [ __ ] movie work to
it and put it on social media does that
make you a [ __ ] comic because comedy
is life and what I've noticed in
watching you at uptown this weekend is
you you are dude from the streets you
come from a hard background but your
audience is mixed you see preppy white
people in here enjoying your comedy you
know why amazing because I actually I'm
actual speech writer it's nothing right
a [ __ ] wonderful speech so the thing
with me is I've learned about Caucasian
people in their palettes their comedy
palettes I'm kind of weird too though
so they kind of find me like he's a he
has a [ __ ] very hard edge to him but
he's the [ __ ] weirdo yeah and he
expresses our weirdy cuz I'm I'm like
I'm not a prison do until something
triggers me to go there you know it's
like a [ __ ] serial killer he might be
cool he won't kill for years and then
something triggers him then he then you
start finding bodies again I don't watch
enough Riddick
you know yo I was dormant for 12 years I
had no desire to kill and then I saw
pink halter top and you saw dropping
bodies everywhere so I wish
was still in here you're gonna if you're
gonna not lay dormant and there was a
joke yes that's funny
um the like last night mm-hmm
that's a place that I would literally be
found in doing stand-up the 1:00 a.m.
show yeah yeah like I would I would
literally I'm a weirdo like that I'd
rather do stand-up then anything else
I'd rather be in the first places the
gutter doesn't matter the audience like
I'd literally kid came from I could've
been at a theater last night sold-out
show theaters [ __ ] to the roof and you
do like you know you're gonna go by this
twit 1 a.m. show up like yeah you ain't
[ __ ] hit a theater yeah yeah so it's
uh it's a what cuz I stand up is that's
my that's my happiest place that's where
I'm the most comfortable and I think
that I don't like the fact that comics
are trying to make comedy like the rap
game I don't want to [ __ ] be in the
rap game I don't know I don't want this
you know it's a craft mm-hmm
you know in you and you should recite
the comedy is starting to get like what
people is doing this one ain't got [ __ ]
else to do and it's one of these Chris
it's the it's the art it's the one in
the [ __ ] most disrespectful
disrespected arts like comics I don't
think that certain comics take this [ __ ]
with with with very I'm someone it's
very serious it's very um this is my
livelihood this is my craft this is what
what I am is just like an art you know
artists you know van Gogh more piano as
Bach Bach would want some random person
playing his music any kind of way you
know you don't you don't put a Picasso
in a ball yeah I'm saying you put it
somewhere to be admired we
stand up we are the purest we're there
we are the most underrated and the most
needy it's like I want to change the
term to like comedy quack but you know
I'm your doctor
I go to medical school I've become a
doctor I study medicine I get engulfed
in medicine and because you can make a
good soup somebody tells you you should
be a doctor hmm because you say
something jovi around your friends
everybody tells my all you should be a
comic no [ __ ] shouldn't be
because you're discrediting what I
actually do you just say anybody should
do what I do because you can boil an egg
that mean you should be a chef [ __ ]
no because you can get takeout and you
can put it on the plate nice that means
you should be a chef you should start
catering comics and people that duck do
comedy any [ __ ] body man any person
that nene leakes is doing [ __ ] comedy
now yeah jake the snake' [ __ ] any
body who decides de you can say
something funny I have some [ __ ]
story now you a comic and we should not
feel any type of way we should just oh
your jovial you should just be okay with
it
why because you're taking a booking out
of some comics yeah
do what the [ __ ] you do do what you do
so you want to start okay I don't play
the NFL no more so let me start telling
funny stories about when I played in the
NFL because I'm I'm I'm in so then
people go see it that we and we deal
with audiences that's not even
intelligent enough we know when
somebody's doing somebody else's [ __ ]
material you know how do you feel about
you being almost 20 years in the game
almost 120 years and you're just now
you've had you've had multiple
TV credits was known easy to run even
reason to run down but now you just
filmed a Comedy Central half-hour you've
been doing comedy most twenty years and
now you're kind of like a new comic to a
lot of you're like the new comic how do
you feel about that
better than being a old comic I'm cool
with being a new kind because I must I'm
such a student of this game and and the
Ellen oh dear let's say this you know
this for sure
cuz he said if anybody ever said I know
they got it from you they heard it from
you because you he's I've been no
comment weight alone he was the first
person I ever heard say comics don't
retire we die oh he died and and then he
said hopefully we could do it on stage
so I knew when I got in to stand up this
was a long tedious thing and a social
media comic but not ever decide to go up
behind or in front of me because you not
equipped son mmm-hmm you you really
lightweight not equipped and so even in
stand-up it's like man I I generally
just try to let everybody do what they
are but when it come to me I know I'm
LeBron I know I'm [ __ ] Magic Johnson
and that's been the hold up with me for
all these years because I'm Magic
Johnson so you get what you get with a
team that wants you to be a point guard
it just wants you to host but you can
headline you can you can do everything
it doesn't matter what you do and you
can do any audience so you got black
people thinking over heat not urban
enough what I'm not what enough mmm oh
because I can go up and do a set without
cursing I can go up and do a set clean
or I can talk real low real time I can
go political satire I can go anywhere in
the comedy world
I go very dark and very weird still can
do it clean and can do it clean so you
don't know where to put me because I'm
not bitching and hoeing the whole time
and it's not just the content but you're
pacing like especially you know I do
both rooms on the urban & quot
mainstream and like there's a stereotype
in urban you got to be in their face
you're pacing I never seen anything like
this and not I've been able to watch you
live specifically over this weekend
seeing you at Uptown and at the 1:00
a.m. show there is no hurry whatsoever
when you get up there you almost want
them to like you're almost like putting
them in a trance almost on your half
hour you sit you walk out and you sit
down in a chair you you go and sit down
in a chair and just hey what's up with
the rest of you like we're please I'm a
student of comedy as well please
enlighten me on that funny the funniest
thing because I'm looking at Joe
responds to it and this is way after it
is already out into them but Comedy
Central the network's response it's like
okay he didn't say he was gonna do that
okay he did ask for a chair in the
warm-up is he gonna [ __ ] sit down so
I walk out and I said just walk on sit
down
hey start an ad in the back like oh [ __ ]
and literally all the execs from Crime
Control up at the time Wow
and then I start and they like we saw it
on his tape that we vetted we saw him
[ __ ] sit down in the crowd in the
theater when I when I on in Auburn big
shout out to Auburn Public Theatre ever
get a chance but you probably because
you I watched you last night man you
you're very good thank you do the Auburn
Public Theatre best place
in the world for stand-up okay they're
listening they're smart it's a theater
it's very nice
so I record my own they asking me for a
tape like okay we want you but we want
to see what you're gonna say they always
want to see what you're gonna say so
they can vet it tell you what you can't
say you know and then put it against
anybody who may be doing a similar line
or something so they do that so the man
is literally seeing that I'm on there
and sit down
sorry cuz I sent these votes in a
30-minute like the the 26 minutes that
you're gonna do or whatever I send the
whole thing this is about a hour and
maybe 45 minutes of me at this theater
from beginning and I come out so they
send it back like okay but what are you
gonna do on the special we watched you
sit down for hour and 45 minutes the
[ __ ] was hysterical but what about these
jokes are you gonna do so I started
picking stuff nice stuff I left out
today so when I come on a thing and I'm
really not gonna do the special to
saying well I did my thing I'm like 9
cuz I I sit down and that's my that's my
thing the only reason I haven't really
actually been sitting down this whole
time at Uptown is because they kept
bringing me bad chairs so I would sit
down the chair would be leaning I was
like someone so uncommon Dragons in the
back and didn't try to keep going around
but the chair thing is very confident
for me it's a very confident thing for
me because I don't want to be rushed I
don't want to be i'ma be out here for at
least an hour hour 20 so I might as well
be comfortable and then it's it's the
process is me me learning and taking
something each year so I've been doing
stand-up
um this is night this year 19 and each
every five years it was every five years
a first thing as I got closer to now I
started taking every yard pick something
and take it and try to master it hmm
like it started with um this guy named
dance white there's why when I first
start doing stand-up there's white would
come out and he would just stand in
front of microphone never move just
stand there and it was [ __ ] stare
and I was like yo les you got to be very
very funny to do that then Paul Mooney
Paul money comes out sits right in the
store never moves so I developed that I
said cuz G in my mind you got to be very
very funny to do that Wow to them after
I got that down Bill Cosby Bill Cosby
sit in that chair the whole time on
himself and then I would see him at bed
um a theater in the symphony opened up
for him and he came out and sat down and
two hours man two hours to out it was
like that it flies I've seen him live
too and it wasn't it wasn't it was
insane mmm so then I said I'm gonna do
that and I'm gonna sit down and then
once I got to sit down thing down I'm on
the road with the L and deals road
manager Gary Monroe at the sign he said
I see you sitting down you think you bag
or you sitting down
if you really Col just walk out there no
music no nothing just walk out there and
I did that I'm some I just walked out
they didn't even say my name or nothin I
just walked out and people talking
getting me food and I'm settling in the
chair and I'm scooting my chair where I
want it put the microphone down and I'm
just sitting in I'm I'm just sitting
there and people start to settle in and
I say whenever y'all ready I'm ready
and then people just started get myself
in mold and then I was like you know
something this [ __ ] is powerful and I'm
having I'm having this this thing in my
head that's Mamadou so I go to this I go
to this College go to this College and
I'm literally on the other side of the
door where the kids going in they can't
see me
and I ain't his do saying oh man we bout
to go this comedy show this comic better
be funny cuz we gonna we gonna tear that
ass up so you gonna give me some
problems
and I'm actually there to explain to
them about the importance of voting
that's what this the the League of young
black voters hired me to explain in
detail voting but from a funny aspect
all these kids jammed into this place
and the man say you want some music you
want anything I said huh
just put a child there say what just put
it out there that man looked at me like
hey man we ain't just a college campus
and they route it right I walk out and I
sat down across my leg and I just said
what do y'all want a name so I'll turn
around huh
what in life do you want outside of this
building I said nobody ever show that
before and you are the people that's
gonna be over my social security in my
health then you don't know what you want
in life so therefore if you don't know
what you want then obviously you don't
know what to vote for or who to vote for
because you don't know what you won't in
voting is about what you won't not about
who you like not about an under arrest
that it's about what do you want in the
policy for you do you understand it show
grandparents live in food deserts if you
can't walk 10 to 15 miles to get fresh
fruit and vegetables you live in a food
desert and you're thinking about you
would show good able to ask body cuz
you're young but what about your
grandmother so you want your grandmother
to be on the goddamn hum around for 15
miles with groceries and nowadays in
their Lane oh [ __ ] ain't even think
about it like that
yeah so now
your grandfather got to be on the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] for 50 50 miles and they like
whoa I end up talking to them kids about
three hours about the jovial funniness
of knowing what voting is knowing about
local elections knowing who they are
knowing who these people are cuz the
presidency ain't gonna affect you about
[ __ ]
uncle kids getting the understanding
because now it's my example of what
Billy Dee Washington told me is how you
develop in this craft because if young
comics understand me the reason why I am
like I am because I've listened to all
the old comics that I respect mm-hmm so
young comics understand is when you're
talking to me and I'm telling you
something this is where it's coming from
verbatim I'm telling you verbatim [ __ ]
out of DL Hughley mouth out of Patrice
O'Neal's mouth out of Bill bird's mouth
out of Chappelle's mouth out of bill
Bellamy's mouth I'm telling you out they
mouth I'm telling you exactly verbatim
what they said to me when I was in times
of crisis and stand-up and I called on
those individuals and Billy Dee
Washington and Rob Stapleton and these
guys who really gave me some jewels in
this game that I did I did I did I
challenged them on they jewels they gave
them to me because I understand that
somebody in this game really don't have
to give you nothing because comedy is
very selfish very self-centered I'm
saying so learning from them and being
up under the tutelage Bruce Bruce Chris
Tucker just getting game from name mouth
anything stick out there you'd like to
share him everything DL I called D I'll
never forget that I called Eli say hey
man this guy I did to show this guy now
he's doing my
actual material mm-hmm and DL said I'm
gonna tell you the same thing that
prince told Timbaland I can never I can
never forget the story
uh-huh because it's two names that I
would even thought they went together
printed something he said Tim Berlin and
in people could remember this and know
if it's true or not at the time Tim
Berlin was hot I'm coming beats crazy
and a lot of people's imitating Tim
Berlin he calls prints this is verbatim
from DL and says prints um a lot of
people out here imitating my sound and
this is what makes the story so
hilarious me cuz DL tried to do a
friend's home to follow me that was
funny he said in prince told Timlin hey
are you that [ __ ] and someone said he
said are you that [ __ ]
yeah then make a new sound and hung up
Wow
and I was in the conversation - cos DL
hung up as well
and so I just right I just started
writing from a different place right
from a different place
Eames and so and he's always told me
things I hate man you think you're gonna
lose no skin in this game he say in this
game in Hollywood you gonna lose some
skin
you gonna maybe sell your soul but at
least keep the [ __ ] receipt so you
can return it is then Wow
so then you got Billy Dee Washington he
say when you not being funny on stage
man at least be interested so that's
what the the conversational part of me
come from yeah I'm very conversational
with the audience because I want to know
in some time I can tell just one-sided
stories the whole time and never and
never because that's what stand-up is
it's a one-sided conversation I say you
laugh I say you laugh I don't need your
response cuz I didn't write that
in I didn't write you're laughing mm-hmm
yeah I don't write laughter and then I
don't write for local that's a lot I
think a lot of times cats to get caught
up in where they are because they don't
understand the industry not hating on
you or some club not hating on you this
club
they won't book me at this club you
don't have a product that I can sell
because what you want to do is come here
and talk about LA in Iowa we don't give
a [ __ ] about LA in Iowa you won't talk
about New York I don't care about you I
don't have a train here I'm in the South
Dakota I don't have a train right what I
have is the commonality between human
beings but if you want to tell me about
Atlanta and I'm in Texas I don't give a
[ __ ] about Atlanta I'd rather you tell
me about the world I really you tell me
about Korea in Atlanta didn't tell me
about Atlanta in Atlanta I'm saying I go
to LA and I la commies come away from LA
and they always want to [ __ ] say oh
I'm living in LA now so and you've done
it all from Houston right did it I did
every drop of from the H and I was and I
was actually I was I did that because I
was so upset that people told me that I
couldn't you had a move to make it man
that's how I feel and I was doing it
before social media I felt like that
before social media before the internet
knowledge and I felt like yo man that I
could literally do stand-up and be a hit
from well I man did everything they do
everybody gotta go to LA everybody how'd
you generate a local following you
aren't they local you they into hell
yeah you it's like you constantly invite
people may not when I started and I
didn't think that was the biggest thing
that I hated about young comics they
everything in social media
when I started I'd literally would
invite anybody to come see me okay any
if every person hey but I do stand up
and be at the spot if you could make it
this time maybe it's one time you may
I'm still going to tell you verbatim out
my mouth that I do stand-up that's who I
am
and people just kept coming to see me in
that rock the reason why they kept
coming to see me they've been seeing me
in Houston for 18 years they can never
say that I'm the same they've watched me
grow from year 1 to year 19 no do I say
the same jokes no am i repeating the
same things I have a hard time doing the
same sit if I'm doing two shows in the
same night I'm not gonna do the same
exact set it's all your writing on stage
where you pinned a paper in the paper
pen to paper today paper I love to hear
that pen to goddamn paper so if you
could and I this will be my final
question I just had to ask you this
because you are one of if not these top
storyteller in this game man it really
has been a treat to watch it live and in
person I would love you just to break
down maybe storytelling from just a
master like you I mean and that's it
that's it they people been saying as
lately they like yo man you are a
phenomenal storyteller mm-hmm and at
first I know how to take that I'm like
the new comer a new joke
so the so it's like you're your joke you
live in a gated community now as well
which is hilarious it's just hilarious
you have a story about like the
neighborhood coming to drop you off
baked goods and you call the police and
all this so maybe even break down how
you develop that into a story from paper
to stage this is this is what actually
this is how that story actually took
place
okay so I'm literally living in this
mood in this gated community and you you
go in like I just am a girl you like and
I'm like okay so she showed me the
brochure in the brochure got everybody
on there literally like literally doing
all the time.she you flipping through
the brochures all time people
doing random different [ __ ] that they
would be doing but it's none of them
oh it's like all until they always was
so right and then I'm coming home one
day and they didn't let me in the gate
and the lady's like do you live over
here I'm like um the only one this is
all I'm like the only one ma'am
I should it should be so easy for me to
get in this game because I am the only
one and if you see another black person
come in as day they're probably with me
they probably know me that so then I
start you know something I am the only
black person over here so I just wrote
the top down only black person in my
neighborhood
okay it's gated they didn't let me
indicate do they think people can't jump
this game so I'm just writing down
things that I think anything okay
I don't lock these stuff up and then
I'll fight em hmm this is weird oh that
was a trap mix yeah and I'm piecing it
together and I'm looking at it and I
said that's crazy I live in a gated
community with all these people and I
know they go change this is my little
time nothing gonna change me I know it I
know [ __ ] about me I like I know they
gonna [ __ ] with it I know it a clown
saying they are so inviting and then I
would get up in the morning and
literally everybody's walking around
[ __ ] they just walking I'm like I'm
not I'm not going out there it's too
early it's too Pleasant I'm not doing it
strugglers and I'm like and I'm seeing
just and then I just start looking at
why I live and everyday I was just
coming I just find something else about
the other line this is crazy
so then I was on stage I mean I'm like I
know eventually people gonna find out
wildly that and I don't want y'all to
judge me because I live in a gated
community and I'm the only black person
over there and I saw no I know but they
tricked me because the brochure was very
boring I'm just start piecing it
together and then the guy knocked on my
door with some other people he's like
maybe like six people mm-hmm
with this Welcome basket welcome to the
neighborhood [ __ ] and I was in there cuz
I was hi I'm smoking and I'm like
alright well we're gonna just leave your
basket of your stuff at the door we
don't know if you're busy in it why
would I be doing it
why would somebody just your door now
crack the door yeah oh we're the Welcome
committee and I'm like this [ __ ] is
crazy I've been to blew it all my life
nobody ever [ __ ] welcomed me to the
neighborhood so it's just a the putting
it and seeing it and piecing it together
and being able to tell it very fluid
from beginning to end with no real point
it's no punch line it's no I'm not
writing punch lines in it I'm telling
the story first and then I start
thinking about the parts that couldn't
be funny but as I'm telling the story
I'm telling the DRI story and it goes
back to when you're not being funny be
interesting because whatever you say
there's interest and eventually turn
funny because you jovial anyway so I'm
telling the story and then it gets to
these pieces of where people like
[ __ ] and then you list you looking at
the audience you seen him like yeah
they're leaning in so so and then the
the only part of the whole story which
is the part that's the weakest the
weakest part of this whole story it's
very weak I don't do it all the time
because I'm not I don't trust it is the
part where I start saying um cuz this is
when it becomes jokey to me like when
you start seeing people outside your
door you start hallucinating and I'm
like I know for some reason I was saying
she that wasn't there I saw a burning
cross I just saw why he was a pitchfork
and then um I'm thinking in my mind they
they called me to come out and I'm
trying to find my gun and I got three
bullets and I'm sitting up against the
thing up there
why do you ego take me out of it like
that and it's it's the weakest part of
it because it's the joke part the rest
of it is the actual story which is good
and then I try to add the joke [ __ ] to
it didn't like no so I never tell that
story I tell the story about when I came
home late at night
and I say you always when you sleepy
just go to sleep don't try to do [ __ ]
because I'm in my house and I put on I
want some tuna fish for some strange
reason it [ __ ] four o'clock in the
morning I put on some eggs put some
boiled eggs on put them on the fish and
I'm watching SportsCenter and I said I'm
[ __ ] dead sleep by the second dunt I
done I'm done
but I got guns out on my house just in
case somebody break in and I wanna be
vulnerable nowhere and remember I'm
sleep and I left him eggs on mmm and
most people know when eggs the water
boil all the way down the eggs pop they
start popping the sound is like that so
I'm [ __ ] disillusioned I'm thinking
my shooting means I didn't drop down off
the couch and I grab my 38 from under
the paint and my mom's in the guest room
and she
comes out what's going on and I hear ha
I say go back
mama days shooting it here these
muhfucka Wow I said to myself cuz I'm
I'm in this it's funny how you can be
intoxicated in sleep mm-hmm you get up
and you you ever you ever been late for
work but you really not late cuz you
running out the house you in the car
you're gonna and you realize it's [ __ ]
Saturday yeah and you didn't need all
you didn't just dress you in a vehicle
your mobile and you literally still
drunk unconscious and you like I'm gonna
be late I'll be late I'm late it's
Saturday so with storytelling you start
from the beginning and you be as
intricate as possible
you tell the very smallest minut points
because that's what makes the story
authentic hmm because you you like when
somebody like I [ __ ] hate on she's
new black because I know it's not one I
hate the [ __ ] name that's racist [ __ ]
I'm saying
why would orange be the new black tell
me why Howard orange are you trying to
say black people are [ __ ] locked up
what are you trying to say but I digress
hmm but the way I hate it oz and I hate
it
orange new black equally because I know
it does not go like that and I'm sitting
like who's telling these fictitious
stories so you grew your nails long and
you slashed somebody in a face like stop
so with your stories you try to just use
as many details as possible
is that really it did um did I do did I
do president take I do the intake story
cuz I don't know I'm doing it on my
special so I know I'm working it I don't
think so
oh my by being naked toe heel to toe no
I didn't hear that one
oh so heel to toe is this something
that's gonna be on my special that's
filmed out of prison
basically we gonna film it at a present
we try to get this clearance um so
anybody know anybody um in Texas who
knows anything about yes we try to keep
one so bad for Comedy Central which the
turnaround is quite fast you do a half
hour this year and then the next year
you have an hour that's it's pretty fast
turnaround I don't know if many people
jump that quick I've been hearing that
I've really been hearing it but I'm very
very ready for our new the new comic I'm
the new comic so darling you and you
knew you should have a ton of it so that
bad aspect of it they intrigued because
they know that I'm saying it's other
people that have been the prisoner they
look and be like yeah that should happen
mmm
because he actually knows like he he
knows knows like it's not like it's not
like this is the separate thing is like
I don't want people to think that I got
like any other person that tells or
prison story like oh like you're like
well Kevin's told that story about his
uncle being in jail different [ __ ] let
me tell the story about um having a
boyfriend he locked up and he got all it
there's something there telling very
general [ __ ] right right you know you
keep the room nice and tidy and I'll
it's very general she anybody [ __ ]
watch any prison show knows that but how
do I get from point A to point B what my
cell look like what else would I do to
my cell
you know what what would I actually do
highs myself set up what's the what's
the what's the social dynamics of this
place what's the social dynamics
everybody like your own you know you all
go you know this fight I don't know it's
not really
ock tell stories about places where I
came from a unit where people were
fighting and then somebody told a man we
don't do that over here we only kill hmm
you don't fight we only kill and this is
that's a that's a real conversation then
somebody telling you in didn't say Amen
get you a knife
and where to go get it from and how to
get it and somebody telling you what
it's gonna be made from and how you
gonna make it and all of this real
technical [ __ ] that you cannot possibly
know unless you're there
yeah like see see see see get it from
see see I just hear that Cece was came
in 1974 Wow wait four years I met Cece
in 1994 really came in 79 with four
years he any I met him in 94 Wow
they turn mark not a long but we good
okay good we'll we'll wrap it up here
we'll wrap it up man thank you so much
for your time in doing this and sharing
all that wisdom and so happy for the
success you've been having
I did ask Billy about a boo story do you
have a quick booze story and your
failure people are always just scared of
you and actually I'm very prepared so I
in mine and which is I don't even say no
knock on wood [ __ ] not never been booed
and every time like me everybody boo I'm
not really mm-hmm
you know I'm not even in the beginning
you know I don't even count
I don't even count the beginning because
it was so [ __ ] sketchy in it okay
well a sock I claimed that one then if
they said well you've been boo hair baby
boo I don't know if this counts or not
but I was start at this place called
just joking comedy cafe and they had a
pollo night all college kids first time
ever going onstage but the difference is
when you go just joking they encourage
booing people right right and it's not
just comics it's rappers poets it's
everybody going up so this day nobody
was getting booed and the hosts felt
like the audience was letting people
make his name is Terry Gross comic so
Kyle's kids I'm green and this would got
my
observational skills to be better I have
on a suit at a college night dreads no
no justjust just no I just came home so
I didn't have locks I okay
bar here so go on stage and this is how
the man says before this is before I go
on stage y'all you bullshitting tonight
somebody gonna get boo I'm saying I
don't know who it is but something bout
y'all here [ __ ] all right
don't boo nobody and let me watch me
talk about y'all and coming to the stage
somebody think they're goddamn comic
give it up for our Lee I walk on stage
and literally hey how y'all doing as I'm
getting booed mm-hmm earthquake is
walking in literally and in my mind I I
developed this phobia every time I saw
earthquake it's like something was
happening with me on stage so the next
time I see him I'm in another Club and
I'm [ __ ] arguing with this dude
I'm killing this dude is tired to say
he's drunk hey how long you gonna be I
said shut your drunk ass up and say
everybody's having a good time
well goddamn I'm trying to dance three
in a dance club earth paint walks in and
I'm arguing just dude I'm like yo man
stop [ __ ] coming places why man man
cuz your buddy say every time I see you
I'm doing I'm going through something so
that's my only time man finish up with
Terry not only did they boo me he did
this thing where he used to dive on the
stage like a missile oh he missile
launched me so boom let me tell you the
cursor that Terry has hated me my whole
entire career I got booed with him the
first time I went on stage I waited two
weeks I came back to the same club jeans
sneakers on I
didn't write comedy down only thing I
just wrote my name hmm
came and I killed came back next week I
killed I came back the next week every
up all night I would only show up - just
joking on a Paula night and I killed so
it's a month of me killing now and now
when I walk in everybody's wondering
Amen you going up there so then the
owner Alice comes to the club my best
friend says hey the owners here no
pressure
she said you killed a knight she gonna
put you up on the weekend and I'm
literally about to walk on stage you
need to my no [ __ ] pressure and I'm
like I go up I [ __ ] killed she come I
comes on stage and she said hey what do
you think about being the co-host on
Apollo night Wow and I said yes I was a
host I was a time post at the club for
about a year and a half and Terri was
the co-host and he [ __ ] hated me
because we had to share the same stage
and we would come on stage after each
other and it was so bad that the club
started to separate itself by audience
if you was him you was down with Terri
and he was cool with Terry and Terry was
your guy you said on this side of the
room if you look down with Allie and we
had two different DJs we had two on the
same stage you said on this side people
would literally sit laughs - laughs just
to be on my side
Wow then my girlfriend at the time this
chick named Lemmy Sheila shale she lives
in Dallas and she is here and she'll say
this story to anybody she commandeered
the back part of the ball on Terry side
so all of her girls from U of H would
sit on that side so it was seem like
Terry's audience was surrounded like
like when I come to say I came out to
DMX Terry came up to some other [ __ ] my
DJ was DJ LaRose he's in Vegas now a DJ
his DJ was DJ red
in Houston so we literally sharing the
same stage to different audiences but we
are both hosting up all night you would
come up I would bring you up as a comic
in saying the people who wasn't gonna
get booed I would bring up everybody who
people was gonna boo and rappers and
[ __ ] like that Terry will bring up and
I'm like because comics I wouldn't I
wouldn't set you up like that I'm saying
but Terry he throw your ass under the
bus and I hated him for that and for
this to this day Terry is one type of
comic and I'm another type of comic and
he started before me and he and he was a
king of Houston into our and so I came
and people run down our TV our credits
and everything
Terry's been on comic view one time 2003
that was it and I tell all young comics
do not take that example of what a
stand-up is cuz the [ __ ] that he used to
say to me oh man we you know let's go
kill the headliner like [ __ ] the
headliner show up it's hosting feature
let's go let's go kill the headliner
does that make them book you mmm
so you want people to be saying oh you
know you was better than the headliner
but them saying people won't come back
and see you by yourself because the
headliner hanging there is the reason
why he's the headliner it's a reason he
got something that he has in any feature
the only thing the only person that can
challenge the headliner is really the
host you have to be a fun night to be a
good a great host
good headline no why because it's a host
you walk out to a cold room every night
yeah a feature you can be a stellar
feature that doesn't mean you can be a
headliner cuz you in a sweet spot
yeah the waves are moving already going
it's right it everything you know you
going in just doing your look popping
you in you off and that's 20 minutes I'm
doing an hour
so I don't think people understand
headliners have a show you put asses in
the seats and like what Billy was saying
and i'ma leave on this one could I take
a little something that popped in my
head I want to say this the quality of
material versus social media guys versus
actual stand-up the problem is that I
spend my actual time writing it
preparing it you spent a lot of time
editing it writing it producing it
redoing it doing it
retake just end the third mm-hmm so you
put a lot of effort into that social
media and you post it and you do that
hey the work beautiful but what you're
saying that you are is you're working
different the greatest comics in the the
most successful comics in the world
asked him how much editing do they do to
a clip ask him how much time they spend
writing a sketch I asked him how many
takes they do to get something on social
media it's a lot it's a lot that goes in
even with this pocket this is a lot and
even though a podcast is simpler then
doing sketches on that it's very simple
this is more ingenious this is more
effective this is more sustaining this
has more nutrients in it then your
bullshit-ass skit that every [ __ ]
cookie cutter it's the same [ __ ]
setup right the [ __ ] at the top or write
it at the bottom get some other people
is this what the [ __ ] is this you're
doing a production to put on a skit but
then you're a [ __ ] show that I pay
money to is [ __ ] and but you call
yourself the same thing is me mm-hmm
you a comic
and I'm a comic how so based on the
words based on the actions the stage do
you get funnier without the stage hmm
gotta be on this thing
how many skits can I do in this room we
can fight a hundred skits in this room
does that I bet and I'm leaving with
this not seeing this with my own eyes
I've heard this from my own ears a
sketch comic a comic gets on social
media guy [ __ ] millions follows I
seen him come to a club that I was
hosting and the new Saint just like this
come on man just do one of your sketches
man [ __ ] boom Ali Siddiq thanks for
being on hot breath my man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
high breath